[Applaudissements]
il est
[Musique]
je sais pourquoi tu t'attendais avec
moyens pas d'histoire de ces justin la
nuit un acquis souffert à laval et que
ton corps ne dérange pas des soi disant
ami guy mettait quessoy jeunes de passe
nous ensemble en est-il et c'est pas une
question de fidélité
le problème ne vient pas nous les hommes
jeunes et
j'ai moi-même et
côté oui j'ai du mal à je sais combien
de femmes et j'ai peur que tu deviennes
mon retour de flamme je te dis j'ai fait
du salat je ne sais combien de femmes et
j'ai peur de dieu devient
montredon de masri tués chauny avec un
corps à poney les hommes sont 108 hier
c'est un projet à
avec le temps tu entre élites et mieux
avec ses panneaux très riche mais je
suis fier
[Musique]
je suis pour
je suis bien
[Musique]
je suis doué
la femme de ken baker givry sur sa faim
dire que tu m'as pas
le mien pris la forme de quelques à ivry
sur sa main veut dire que tu me vois
j'ai toujours pas toi tu t'attendais les
hommes n'ont pas grandi dans la logique
de venir plus des amis je sais toujours
pas ce que tu t'attendais tu enlèves
mois souscrit toutes ces bêtises ton
esprit soit pas la crise non mais tu me
dois dessous de tout et de tout le monde
en commençant pas s'exposer c'est jeudi
méfie-toi dessous de tout et de tout le
monde sait que mon tout finira pas
oui j'ai levé du mal à je ne sais
combien de femmes et j'ai peur que tu
deviennes mon retour de flamme rouge pdg
vécu sa jeunesse
combien de femmes et j'ai peur que d'une
vie
et
ma chérie tu es jolie avec un copain
police les hommes sont sans pitié
interdit d approcher balotelli
[Musique]
khatami qui je suis je suis
je suis fier
vidéo
je suis qu'à nous et
la femme de quelqu'un qui brille sur ça
veut dire que tu vas pas
on fait
créé la femme de kent
sur ce
hugo dumas part-dieu jeu
leroux je suis jalouse
[Musique]
mais willig mieux sauter mais ce jeune
homme
j'ai confiance en toi mais je suis
jaloux [ __ ] j'ai confiance en toi mais
sujet
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
merci merci à tous
addou